>> Tammy: MY NEXT GUEST HAS
GONE FROM CONCERNED PARENT LIKE
MANY OF YOU TO LEGAL ACTIVIST,
NOT ONLY CONFRONTING THE WOKE
TEACHERS IN HIS DISTRICT BUT
TAKING IT ONE STEP FURTHER.
IAN PRIOR LOOKED INTO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN HIS HOME TOWN,
LOWDEN COUNTY, VIRGINIA AND GOT
HIS HANDS ON SOME OF THEIR
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS INCLUDING
PART OF A PRESENTATION DELIVERED
BY THE LOWDEN COUNTY EQUITY
DIRECTOR.
IT'S HARD TO READ THE FINE PRINT
BUT IT'S ESSENTIALLY A TOOL TO
HELP BRAIN WASH TEACHERS INTO
BELIEVING THAT WHITE CHRISTIANS
ARE PRIVILEGED.
SO EVERYONE ELSE IS, OF COURSE,
BY DEFAULT OPPRESSED.
IAN PRIOR, THE FATHER WHO
UNCOVERED THESE DOCUMENTS JOINS
ME NOW.
IAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT YOU.
I'VE SEEN A GREAT DEAL OF YOUR
WORK.
YOU ALSO STARTED UP A WEBSITE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN CHIME IN WITH
THE THINGS THAT ARE HELPING --
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THEIR
DISTRICT WHEN IT COMES TO
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
TELL ME WHAT STARTED ALL OF THIS
OFF FOR YOU?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THIS REALLY
STARTED OFF IN MARCH WHEN THERE
WAS A GROUP OF FOLKS IN A
PRIVATE FACEBOOK GROUP INCLUDING
SIX SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THAT
WERE CALLING FOR TARGETING
PARENTS FOR SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
THAT REALLY MOTIVATED PEOPLE
ACROSS IDEOLOGICAL LINES, YOU
KNOW, REALLY EVERYBODY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON IN OUR
SCHOOLS, WHY HAVE WE CREATED A
CULTURE OF BULLYING IN OUR
SCHOOLS, IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
IS AFFECTING PARENTS AND
AFFECTING STUDENTS?
IT'S REALLY SORT OF TEARING THE
COMMUNITY APART.
WE STARTED DOING OUR DUE
DILIGENCE.
THERE'S A LOTS OF PEOPLE OUT
HERE THAT ARE -- THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT HERE THAT ARE
SENDING FOILS TO LOWDEN COUNTY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS UNCOVERING ALL OF
THESE DOCUMENTS THAT REALLY SHOW
THE DIVISIVE NATURE OF WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO INDOCTRINATE
OUR TEACHERS WITH AND THEN WHAT
OUR TEACHERS WOULD THEN
INDOCTRINATE OUR TEACHERS WITH.
-- OUR CHILDREN WITH.
IT'S APPALLING.
>> Tammy: THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT REQUEST -- AT
THE SAME TIME, YOU MAKE A REALLY
GOOD POINT.
THIS IS THE TEACHERS UNION THAT
SEEM TO BE MOVING THIS.
AND NOT EVERY TEACHER -- WE'VE
SEEN TEACHERS PUSH BACK AND
LEAVE AND GO PUBLIC AND MANY ARE
AS SHOCKED AS WE ARE, BUT A LOT
OF THIS MATERIAL IS, IN FACT, TO
INDOCTRINATE THE ADULTS TO
CONTINUE, BECAUSE MANY ADULTS
ARE THINKING, WHY ARE WE DOING
THIS TO CHILDREN?
AND ESPECIALLY KEEPING
CLASSROOMS CLOSED.
TEACHERS ARE THINKING THIS IS
CRAZY AS WELL.
ARE YOU FINDING THAT TEACHERS
ARE SUPPORTING YOU IN THIS AS
YOU GO THROUGH THIS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
SO WE SET UP A POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE FIGHT FOR SCHOOLS
DOT-COM.
WE'RE GETTING ALL KINDS OF TIPS
EVERY DAY.
A LOT OF TIPS COME FROM PARENTS.
A LOT OF IT COMES FROM TEACHERS.
TEACHERS ARE FED UP WITH HAVING
TO GO THROUGH THIS -- THESE
BRAINWASHING SESSIONS THEM JUST
DON'T WANT TO TEACH -- SESSIONS.
THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO TEACH
THE KIDS THIS STUFF.
THEY'RE PETRIFIED TO SPEAK OUT
BECAUSE THEY FEAR REPERCUSSIONS
FROM THE SCHOOL UNION AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
THEN THEY'LL BE BRANDED --
>> Tammy: THIS IS WHERE -- AND
YOU CAN'T GET HIRED ELSEWHERE,
RIGHT?
THEN IT'S A MATTER OF WHERE DO
YOU GO?
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO YOUR KIDS.
YOU'VE GOT THE SCHOOL BOARDS --
AND EVEN IN SAN FRANCISCO,
THEY'RE RECALLING THREE MEMBERS
OF THE SCHOOL BOARD UP THERE.
THEY WOULD RECALL ALL OF THEM,
BUT THEY'RE NOT IN THE RIGHT,
YOU KNOW, TIMELINE OF BEING ABLE
TO DO SO.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR?
SO IN ADDITION TO GATHERING
INFORMATION, WHAT DO YOU HOPE IS
GOING TO COME FROM THIS?
WHERE DO YOU WANT THIS TO GO?
>> SURE, REALLY IT'S
INVESTIGATE, COMMUNITY AND
ACTIVATE.
WE'VE BEEN DOING THE
INVESTIGATION WITH FOYEZ AND THE
INVESTIGATION WITH TALKING TO
TEACHERS AND TALKING TO PARENTS
AND THEN WE COMMUNICATE IT.
WE GET IT OUT THERE AND SHINE
THE SPOTLIGHT OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THE SCHOOL BOARD, ON THE
SYSTEM.
AS FAR AS ACTIVATING, THAT'S WHY
WE SET UP FIGHT FOR SCHOOLS
DOT-COM SO WE CAN THEN ENGAGE IN
A RECALL ELECTION, IN A RECALL
PETITION TO GET THE SIX SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS OFF THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
THEY WERE IN A PRIVATE FACEBOOK
GROUP ROOM WHERE CRIMES WERE
BEING SUGGESTED AND THEY DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> Tammy: WELL, IAN, YOU'RE AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
RADICALIZED BECAUSE OF WHAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON CONGRATULATIONS,
SIR, AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING U